[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh washington goes to carolina and beats
carolina at home against seattle on
monday night will be their next game so
uh two in a row with washington beating
the buccaneers and their head coach ron
rivera joining us on the program how's
morale coach
you know after winning it's a lot better
that's for sure
but when you go into a game like that
what kind of emotions do you have it's
you know it's one thing to go on the
road it's another thing to sort of go
back home or your home away from home so
how do you how do you fight those or
deal with those emotions
well you know one of the things that we
talked about going into the week i told
the players i said you know it's going
to be an interesting thing i'm coming
back or going back and you know cam's
going to be there as well i said so it's
going to be interesting so let me focus
on what's interesting you guys focus in
on playing the game don't worry about
what i say don't worry about how i gush
about being over there that whole thing
you guys have to focus on the game and
so we tried to keep it separate we
really did and quite honestly then it
was good to go back because i got a
chance to see a lot of a lot of good
friends
what was it like drawing up a game plan
to go against cam
you know it's interesting because we
were trying to figure out you know what
are they going to put into the game plan
what are they going to use how deep can
they get into their playbook you know
because you look at what they did with
their other quarterbacks and you say
okay
this will fit cam that won't fit cam um
and then you look at what what cam had
done the previous year with new england
and then you try to remember what cam
was doing when he was with us back in
the day so there were a lot of things
that you know we were trying to kind of
figure out it was tough it wasn't that
but i think what jack and and and and
the defensive staff came up with that
that was pretty good
tougher coming up on the game plan for
cam or the previous week with tom brady
oh tom brady tom brady um you know
he's different i mean there's so many
things that he can do and you have to
prepare for that
with with with cam you know you know
what he does well and you really believe
that's what they're going to do with
them now he has some good weapons and
christian mccarthy is as good a weapon
as there is in this league and i think
dj moore's a guy that you know every
time he gets the ball he's an explosive
player too
what were you trying to get brady to do
gosh the biggest thing was we were
trying to trying to connect to his
routes to to his his receivers and and
get him to hold that ball just a touch
longer than he's used to and if we could
do that we felt we had a chance
i talked to drew brees in the first hour
and i said you know what's it like when
you get older and he said well you know
all the answers to the test
but but that doesn't mean you can go out
and perform when you have all answers to
the test but when you face someone like
brady is there anything that you could
possibly do that he has not seen before
no
there really isn't i mean you the
biggest thing you try to do is you try
to affect him one way the other whether
it's to get your your rush close to him
or it's whether to get close to his
receivers to get him to you know to hold
it just for a second or get him off his
mark if you can do that you have a
chance
uh what do you tell your guys about the
taunting rule um don't put yourself in
the position where the referees got to
make a decision
in other words just don't do it i mean
again if you want to celebrate that's
great look to us now we got we got one
last week
and you know i'm not a big fan of of why
it was called
but again i get it you know it's it's
one of those things that
you know just just don't don't don't do
something that's going to put that
referee in that position to make that
decision where do you think this came
from well what it came from was it came
from the fights that had broken out the
last couple of seasons that really
turned into melees that were you know
were
quite honestly you know
what you don't want to see out there and
so when we talked about it we debated it
in the committee was guys you know we
don't want guys that are going to come
out and and do something that's going to
create something else to to escalate
okay and that's really what the whole
idea and the idea behind it is don't
give these guys a chance to have this
stuff happen i mean we've had some
pretty bad stuff where we had tampa new
orleans new orleans chicago we had the
stuff that went on with with uh with
denver and the raiders you know and
that's why you don't want those things
to happen on that field because we got a
great game we got a good thing going
here and the last thing we want to see
is something like that to happen and
then something worse to happen where
somebody gets hurt during something like
that
and i wonder and even at the beginning
of the year i wondered if this was going
to be something that could affect the
outcome of a playoff game right oh that
that's the scary thing that's the truth
of the matter i mean
you know but but honestly don't do
something that's going to you know
that's going to deter i assume that's
going to take away from from the game
we're trying to stop it we're trying to
get guys to understand hey let's yeah
you know hey you want to celebrate you
want a good time go do it run to the
other end zone okay run to your bench
run to your teammates but you know don't
turn and look at the other team and
and point your finger or drop the ball
at them in their face you know because
that's that's what that's what we're
trying to prevent we're trying to
prevent the next big brawl
your quarterbacking situation
it's fun um we have a we have a guy
that's got a lot of personality he's got
a little bit of swagger right now
feeling pretty good about some of the
things that he's done um but he's a
golfer that works hard
he competes um he also one of those guys
that that
you know if you keep yourself close to a
game you feel like you have a chance to
win and i think that's what his
teammates are feeling because of who he
is best team that you've faced this year
oh wow um gosh
i mean we we we we played some pretty
good teams i mean i i think tampa is a
you know right up there even though you
know they they they lost to us
you know they're still a team and you
sit there and say man this is there's a
good group of guys that just as they
start coming again you know if they do
like they did last year they find that
part where they get hot yeah
they're going to be scary you know um i
still like buffalo you know
they're a team that really you know um i
like the way kansas city can be
explosive you know we bottled them up
for for right into the middle of third
quarter then all of a sudden patrick
mahone's you know
went crazy against us
um i mean there are some pretty
formidable teams that we have faced that
that again that when they
do what they're capable of they're
pretty doggone good what's the best
piece of memorabilia you got in the
office
god lee there i got a lot of them i
really do i've been very fortunate you
know when you're in the late for 30
something years you'll see i one of my
favorites i got a photo of my my father
and my my three brothers when we did the
usaa commercials
um you know i keep that up there because
i lost my one of my brothers to
pancreatic cancer he's in that picture
and it's actually the last picture all
four boys were with my dad that's
awesome big deal
where's the super bowl ring
i don't have the super wearing but i do
have over here in the corner i got
the replica trophy they gave us at the
uh one of the reunions that we had it's
really kind of cool
you know i i'll bring in the office that
way if any players sit there and look at
it i can sit there and reminisce a
little bit and tell them i'm telling you
if we can get one guys you'll never
forget it
you had seven and a half sacks in your
career
can you name all the quarterbacks you
sacked
gosh uh probably not um it was a long
time ago
it's only seven and a half sacks coach
though i mean it's not reggie white here
no because reggie believe me reggie
would have
told me that he'd still be naming him
i'll be done very quickly
um
no but uh you know i had uh gosh yeah
did you get a hall of famers or is there
like oh yeah i got a hall of fame in
fact my last nfl sack uh was brett favre
and and when i started coaching brett
was still playing
and so we were on the you know we were
pregame we were sitting there talking to
bs
and he said something about me and i say
hey let me tell you something now i want
you to know you were my last nfl side
he looked at me he goes damn i was slow
then
[Laughter]
that was 92 i think right yes it was it
still was it was it was oh yeah
dang i'll tell you that's that's the way
to bring those memories back how you
feeling
i'm feeling good thank you you know um
i'm in my 13th month of recovery they
tell me it's about an 18-month process
maybe two years but i've been good all
of my all of my scans and everything
have come up negative all of my doctor
reports have all been positive so things
are going well knocking on wood and it's
been good would you rather that people
ask or didn't ask
i'd rather they ask because i tell you
because every time people talk to me
about it i always make a pitch for um
for uh for
for people to to
take care of themselves self-check
self-report you know i mean i was very
fortunate i caught it when i was shaving
i felt a lump in my neck that just
didn't feel right
and
because of that i reached out to my
doctor
a lot of people they feel something they
don't reach out and i tell them one of
the things the doctors told me was
because i caught it early and did
something about it
and that's what i tell people when they
ask so you find the lump do you call a
doctor that day
um i called him the next day my throat
was a little sore and so he you know
took a look and said you know yeah
you're right you throw it maybe it is so
they gave me some medicine
um i was going on vacation the next day
so but when i got back it was still
there so then i went and saw him again
he said let's keep an eye on it for a
week come back and see me nothing
changed and that's when we went and and
he he put the ball in uh and got it
rolling
congrats on the wins coach and more
importantly i'm glad you're feeling
better happy thanksgiving
cool happy thanksgiving to you dan thank
you that's ron rivera washington
football team head coach two-time nfl
coach of the year